[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Valérie Savouret
conseillère formatrice au sein de
bg-yvelines bonjour bonjour enchanté
d'être là avec vous aujourd'hui
n'accompagne les Yvelinois dans la
création d'entreprises on va revenir
justement sur vos différents
accompagnements vos actions et vos
activités tout au long de cette émission
avant ça pouvez-vous nous présenter
justement BGV Yvelines et depuis quand
était l'implanté implanté par nous dans
les Yvelines alors BG Evelyne est
implanté depuis 30 ans en fait c'est
notre anniversaire aujourd'hui notre 30e
année d'implantation dans les Yvelines
il faut savoir qu'on fait partie du
réseau des BGE et ce réseau existe
depuis 43 ans depuis 1979 exactement
d'ailleurs vous accompagner les
personnes dans la création ajustement de
leur entreprise quelles sont justement
les étapes de la création d'une
entreprise et quel est votre rôle dans
cet accompagnement alors vous avez
raison de parler d'étape c'est très très
important pour un porteur de projet de
comprendre qu'il y a des étapes à
respecter et à suivre pour valider un
projet de création d'entreprise
donc on a la première étape en fait
c'est d'abord ça paraît évident c'est
savoir ce qu'on veut faire donc
formaliser son offre c'est ce qui va
permettre de décliner toute la
préparation d'un projet de création
d'entreprise avec analyse de ses
compétences personnelles au vu du projet
qu'on veut faire être sûr qu'il y a une
cohérence
l'étude de marché qui est vraiment
l'aspect de très très important d'un
projet parce que c'est ce qui vous
permet de valider qu'il y a un marché et
que vous avez votre place sur ce marché
l'analyse financière qui permet de
valider que votre projet est faisable et
rentable et puis après on choisit la
structure juridique en fonction de tous
ces éléments et on s'y matricules et
donc je vais insister sur ce point si
vous me permettez
on a beaucoup de personnes qui
immatriculent leur entreprise en début
de projet et non pas à la fin donc en
fait elles ont tout à fait après leur
immatriculation et puis après il y a des
déconvenus parce que on va peut-être en
parler après de savoir leur crainte et
ainsi de suite et bien plus auront
préparé leur dossier en amont plus elles
seront prêtes quand les immatriculteurs
quand elles immatriculeront leur
entreprise pour se lancer dans cette
grande aventure et déjà commencé à avoir
des clients donc déjà le meilleur
conseil c'est de ne pas s'immatriculer
dès le début c'est vraiment de
d'attendre d'avoir fait plusieurs étapes
donc les étapes que vous venez de citer
avant de s'y matriculer complètement
c'est vraiment si on peut retenir une
chose de cette émission au cours de
cette émission c'est attendez pour vous
immatriculer il n'y a pas d'urgence ça
se fait facilement il y a un site pour
ça maintenant c'est les étapes
préalables qui sont importantes pour
aller chercher des clients déjà alors
justement vous l'avez évoqué créer une
entreprise peut faire peur peur de mal
faire peur de se sentir seul ou tout
simplement d'échoué comment est-ce que
vous rassurez justement les personnes
qui viennent vous voir mais qui
ressentent ces inquiétudes alors j'ai
envie de dire c'est normal d'avoir peur
je préfère que des gens aient peur mais
qu'au final il valide toutes les étapes
dont on a parlé et que quand ils vont
créer en fait ils sont déjà assuré
d'avoir fait les choses dans le bon
ordre et on va les rassurer alors tout
dépend des questions qui vont être
posées c'est sûr que souvent ils
viennent aussi avec une question sur les
choix déstructures juridiques là on va
avoir avec eux en fonction justement de
leur de leurs impératifs personnels de
leur activité on va les aider à choisir
la structure qui nous paraît la plus
adéquate par rapport à leur projet et ça
ça va les rassurer il y a tout un
interrogation par rapport à
l'immatriculation maintenant il y a on
peut être accompagné pour s'immatriculer
c'est pas ça le plus compliqué la peur
effectivement mais ce qu'il faut ce dont
il faut s'assurer c'est les clients et
là je vais insister les clients et les
clients et justement est-ce que par
exemple un projet qui vient on va pas
dire un peu brouillon mais qui qui
émerge finalement grâce à vous peut
devenir une véritable entreprise et un
véritable projet parce que vous vous
êtes là aussi pour justement leur dire
là il faut peut-être recentrer un petit
peu plus là il faut bien voir comment ça
va se passer etc c'est tout à fait ça en
fait on va les aider déjà à prendre
en compte la nécessité de savoir
formaliser son projet pour après le
décliner en prestation de service en
vente de produits et puis après donc on
va dérouler tout l'accompagnement et là
en fait à chaque étape de
l'accompagnement on va mettre on va
pointer du doigt ce qui va ce qui peut
être les informations peut-être à
rechercher pour valider que le projet
est réalisable et qu'ils ont réponse à
toutes les questions qu'il faut se poser
pour créer son entreprise dans les
bonnes conditions alors depuis 1993 la
BGE Yvelines accompagné près de 15 300
projets et à aider à la création de 7700
entreprises pourquoi est-ce qu'il est
important de montrer et prouver au futur
entre eux entrepreneurs pardon qu'une
entreprise ne se fait pas seul et qu'ils
peuvent être accompagnés avoir un regard
extérieur c'est vraiment important
alors puis alors j'ai une expression que
j'ai dit souvent à mes porteurs de
projet allégé volatir c'est sorti de
chez vous en fait si vous êtes tout seul
sur votre projet en fait vous allez pas
vous allez pas avoir de contradictions
en fait c'est facile il y a pas de
contradiction mais néanmoins on va se
faire un petit peu les futurs clients et
on va amener les personnes à se poser
des bonnes questions et peut-être
d'autres questions que celles qui ne
enfin qu'ils peuvent avoir abordé ils
vont peut-être sortir un petit peu de
leur zone de confort mais c'est c'est
important d'être en confrontation avec
d'autres personnes
proposent également un appui conseil
avant la création alors qu'est-ce que ça
signifie elle a pu conseille c'est tout
cet accompagnement individualisé ou
justement on va tenir compte de la
personne de son projet de son expérience
de ce qu'elle veut faire ou elle veut
s'implanter et on va par un appui
personnalisé on va la conseiller sur ce
qu'elle peut faire ce qui est moi elle
devrait envisager son projet quelle
démarche elle doit elle peut être amenée
à faire
et c'est ça en fait la pluie conseil
c'est de l'accompagnement donc juste
vous dites un bon mot
nous conseillons nous accompagnons mais
nous ne faisons pas à la place d'eux
c'est important
qui reste autonome sur son projet et on
va lui donner en fait des clés des
directives des orientations après c'est
lui qui va décider en fin de compte si
il crée ou pas
mais donc nous nous conseillons nous
devons faisons pas à la place de c'est
important alors des financements et aide
sont disponibles vous les avez un petit
peu un petit peu évoqué on ne les
connaît pas toujours alors est-ce que
vous informer justement sur sur ces
financements et quels sont les
financements qui sont possibles qui
existent à la création d'entreprise
alors il y a une pluralité de
financement qui va être adapté aux
besoins de chaque chef d'entreprise et à
leur spécificité et
en fait j'ai envie de dire même une
personne qui est au RSA une personne qui
est handicapée on va lui indiquer les
financements qui vont être en adéquation
avec sa situation c'est important de
savoir
c'est pas parce qu'on est au Reza
demandeur d'emploi qu'on va pas avoir de
financement
donc oui une personne qui vient avec un
besoin de financement on va l'orienter
vers les financeurs qui sont en
adéquation avec leur projet et leur
situation alors on peut citer plus
généralement les réseaux initiatiques
les réseaux français activent on a la
dit on a d'autres réseaux à leur locaux
on a les réseaux entreprendre et puis
sur les Yvelines on a aussi le
département des Yvelines on doit aussi
la face donc chaque organisme de
financement va avoir ces critères de
financement et c'est ça qui au long d'un
accompagnement va nous permettre
d'adresser un dossier à telle financeur
plutôt qu'un autre en fonction des
caractéristiques du projet et vous
proposez également des ateliers et des
formations alors quelles sont ces
ateliers et ces formations que vous
proposez alors on va commencer par les
ateliers donc les ateliers c'est des
des en fait des des mini formation d'une
durée courte de trois heures
et il y a notamment un atelier sur les
étapes de la création d'entreprise en
fait qui est aussi une porte c'est une
pour nous une porte d'entrée pour qu'un
porteur de projet justement il sache
quels sont les étapes de la création
d'entreprise et pouvoir savoir où il en
est par rapport au son projet quand il
vient nous voir donc on a des ateliers
en fait c'est des mini formation assez
qualitatifs sur le contenu par exemple
sur l'assurance sur les les modalités
les différents financements qui peuvent
exister
on a un atelier sur la fiscalité donc
c'est déjà avoir donné un porteur de
projet des clés d'information pour son
projet et après on a on propose des
formations qui vont être d'une journée
ou deux
c'est vraiment pour renforcer les
compétences transversales d'un chef
d'entreprise d'un futur chef
d'entreprise donc on a toujours la même
thématique elle est compétences
transversales c'est la gestion au sens
large financière Gestion des ressources
humaines et puis ensuite tout l'aspect
commercial où on va
former on a une formation sur justement
savoir comment négocier avec un client
c'est important et puis il y a aussi
maintenant toute la thématique autour du
numérique donc ça c'est vraiment au sens
large l'aspect ce qu'on appelle le
saspect commercial et puis il a fait
juridique alors quelle structure
juridique choisir et notamment on a une
formation aussi phare sur la
micro-entreprise qui est une structure
juridique qui est beaucoup
choisi de nos jours mais c'est important
d'en comprendre les avantages et les
inconvénients on peut aussi vous vous
retrouver grâce au bus création de
d'entreprises en quelques mots il sera
reconduit en 2023 justement alors il y a
des propositions en cours on est en
attente de réponse mais effectivement si
on sera ravi de vous recevoir c'est
justement merci beaucoup Valérie
savourer d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation pour plus d'informations on
peut se rendre sur le site BGE 78.fr et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]